joined by former England international
and Premier League footballer John
Barnes hey John good to see thanks for
joining us what on earth is it coming to
when the color of his skin
makes you a target for abuse I thought
we'd seen the back of this I don't know
why you thought we seen the back of it
because I didn't think we've seen the
back of it as much as we haven't heard
it for a while I think probably the most
pertinent and question that has to be
asked in all of the the data and the
survey that's been done because we've
done a lot of surveys as to whether
people's heard it
whether people seen it have they
reported it I would like to see a survey
asking people if they've ever done it if
they've ever have originally sexual from
a sexist point of a homophobic point of
view if they've ever abused anyone on
football match and I'm sure the answer
will be no it'll be no percent so 86% of
people would have heard it but no
percent of people would have actually
done it and that's the big problem I
can't be afraid to come forward and say
that they've done it okay so if we
hadn't seen the back of it did you think
that it that we were getting better as
fans at behaving ourselves on I was
gonna I'm gonna say the terraces I think
in terms of overt racism we have been
better at controlling ourselves and our
emotions all you've done is kept you
kept our mouths shut and of course in
the last 18 months maybe because we've
become a little bit complacent you've
now seen its rear its ugly head but as I
said it's not just those two men at West
Ham who racially abused Raheem Sterling
or the two who racially abused most are
at West Ham but that's why I'm saying a
more pertinent question if you want to
do a real poll is to ask me who were
they've ever done it and they have to
not be afraid to admit that yes I've
done it because of their have been
brought up I was wrong to think that
I've sought help I'm disgusted I'm
ashamed of myself
somebody did do that in there that was
Liam Neeson and look at the outcome of
that so therefore people are now gonna
be more afraid to come forward and it
has to start the conversation as to who
has actually done it without being
afraid of coming out and saying it and
saying I can't help it that's what I was
brought up I am wrong but that
conversation needs to be had you think
it is gonna be had they gave him what
you just said it's not going to be had
because people are now afraid to come
forward because of our antha Liam Neeson
Liam Neeson said I'm ashamed of myself
I'm embarrassed it was 40 years ago I
sought help and now I think differently
and look at the response to that so how
can we say to a football fan in
the truth and reconciliation come
forward if you've done it and if you
want to come up it's not an excuse it's
a reason as to the way you've been
brought up as the way the media portrays
different groups of people different
women and homosexuals so therefore it's
understandable but unless you are going
to be admitting it very much like I'm
not alcoholic the first thing you have
to say is I'm an alcoholic you can't
make excuses but if if you're afraid of
being completely slaughtered because you
come out in you're honest then you say
you've got help no one's going to admit
it he's gonna drive it even further on
the ground the sports minister wants
politicians police and clubs to come
together towards the end of this month
to try to come up with some solutions we
just heard in those Fox pops as we
called them one of the fans who was
racially abused he said that he
approached one of the stewards because
he'd had enough but he doesn't expect
the club to do anything about it
well clubs football clubs can't change
people's perception it's been going on
for hundreds of years people's
perception and misconception of the
worthiness of someone who's black of a
woman of a transsexual of a homosexual
the media shows us to the last 200 years
and continues to show us there are some
people who are more worthy than others
wrongly show us so of course when you
have these perceptions it got absolutely
nothing to do with football it has to do
with society and until we chart change
society on the ban and the misconception
people have in society of other groups
nothing's gonna change we can pass laws
you can get people banned but that's
been going on for 30 years in football
and nothing's changed we have to take a
different approach presumably what we
can do while looking at what other
options are available and presumably
this working group at the end of
February will be looking more into that
if somebody next to you on the terraces
shouts racial abuse either at another
fan or somebody on the pitch they should
have their voice and be able to say
that's not acceptable and the club
should then take action against that
person surely absolutely absolutely of
course because of course that's the rule
of law and maybe they'll go to prison
maybe they'll get banned but you have to
look at the deeper issue as to why he
wants to say that and what makes it say
that but you have to tackle the cause
the symptom which racial abuse what is
the cause of it and until you tackle the
cause of it
- then deconstruct the idea of racial
superiority which comes from somewhere
it doesn't come from him going to a
football match and thinking I'm gonna
shout this out it comes from somewhere
and until we can actually
cause it'll always continue to happen
what should the players do I think a
pardon what should players do what
should the players do yeah
players should play football that's what
players should do that's all it's not up
to a player to then cure the ills of the
world and if he doesn't cure the ills of
the world by walking off he's then gonna
be called an apologist for racism not at
all
the authorities can't do anything either
because I'm a football stadium if you
just keep your mouth shut
for 90 minutes but if you other six days
of the week while you're not on a
football match you can be as racially
biased as you like that is the big
problem it is a problem in society and
you cannot throw it at the door of
football because before you are racist
football fan you are racist member of
society
and a society's problem not just in
football I read as I was preparing for
our interview John there was a group of
female football players and they were
sexist that they had sexual comments
shouted at them they the game was
stopped they chose to sit down on the
pitch and they wouldn't leave the pitch
you don't think that that's the right
way forward to a highlight whatever the
issue might be on that case well well
the football games will be stopped every
single week every game would be stopped
so of course and I think what's going to
make them stop shouting sexiest abuse
and do we want to we do want to get rid
of sexism or we just don't want to hear
it so what can happen for those ladies
who sat down is that at football matches
then those sexist people will then not
shout sexist abuse but for the rest of
their everyday life they can be a sexist
as they want because what you're
actually saying is that it's not a
problem society's just in football now
those people who shouted sex sexist
abuse at those girls
what do they do Monday to Friday they
have sexist opinions so it's not just in
football and football can do nothing
about changing their perception your
final word to this Sports Minister if
they're watching this afternoon as I
said the question I would like to be
asked we put out there is who has
shouted racist homophobic or Six's abuse
at a football match and then when you
see that no percent or one percent of
people who say we did it you'll have to
ask the question how can 86 percent of
people hear it when nobody's doing it oh
oh yes it's um those two fans from West
Ham they're the only ones they get
around the whole ground
every single week all around the country
they're the ones doing it because we're
all innocent we are all culpable